[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome the
simulation I'm your host Don Saki on
very excited to be talking about digital
currency talking about blockchain
talking about what's at stake
we have Brock Pierce joining us on the
show hello hi hey thanks for coming on
thank you for having me I'm very excited
very excited we have so much to discuss
Brock Pierce is a crypto pioneer a
philanthropist community leader having
raised more than five billion dollars
for companies he has founded he's the
chairman of the Bitcoin foundation and
co-founder of Eos Alliance block one
block chain capital tether and master
coin and you can find Brock's links
below as well as Twitter in Brock let's
start things off on this big history
perspective we find ourselves as
stewards of earth what's your current
take on the state of humanity
well I your choice of words stewards and
the stewardship is you know probably one
of the main things that's missing you
know too many humans wanting to be the
boss too many humans trying to be
leaders and not understanding that what
that really ultimately means is to be
stewards you know that's what real
leadership is and you know as things
change ultimately the leaders of the
future are going to be stewards that's
what's going to separate us some so
state of humanity today who you know
it's it's a little scary at times but
I'm I'm an optimist I'm very hopeful I
believe that you know if we were living
in a you know call it the neverending
story or some people like to call it a
simulation if you know however you want
to describe this wonderful place this
wonderful world in which we live you
know it would have to be better than
like any movie right if it has to be
better than any story you've ever read
you know so it's going to happen it's
got to have a good ending or right you
know it
it throughout that story it's gonna it's
gonna you know get tough and you know
you're gonna have your moments of doubt
and you know but it's always I think the
darkest before the dawn so I yeah I I
see the light at the end of the tunnel
yeah yeah I in us yeah yeah and what
would be a core principle or skill to
develop to become a better steward well
it I think it's mostly about putting you
know others before yourself but not
always there's a there's an order to
this and there's a nuance to and one of
the keys I discovered to happiness is
that I've never met a happy person
that's very selfish yeah that's not to
say that we don't all have to be
somewhat selfish I mean it's kind of
like on the airplane in the video it's
like you know put your mask on first
before taking care of others but once
you get your house in order you know the
key to happiness is evolving beyond
selfishness to selflessness it's taking
that me and flipping it upside down into
we and so you know that's really what
stewardship is you know leaders and
people that are trying to grab power you
know the people that want to be
President and people that want to be CEO
you know are often those that are taking
care of themselves you know the best
presidents the best CEOs the best
leaders are the ones that don't want the
job you know it's the ones that show up
in service which is ultimately stewards
it's people that make sure that
everybody else is taken care of before
themselves it's the people to eat last
you know the people that make sure you
know those those are the leaders that
were ultimately looking for is stewards
and you know as you figure out in life
who you want to follow and who you want
to listen to and where you want to get
your guidance from you know identifying
you know the stewards from the leaders
and being able to you know identify that
will serve you pretty well in life
stewards are normally you know good
people to follow you know as I like to
say too because I can't you can't always
serve everyone right there's not enough
time in the day I always say I live my
life in service and you know I I'm in
service to those that are in service
first and foremost yeah
yeah that's very that's very profound
and I think that it gives us a very
strong way to live our life by embodying
that skillset and that principle of
being a steward first and foremost we
sometimes we need our awareness expanded
to realize that we are steward sometimes
it and so these are maybe some of the
these potential experiences especially
as we get into the ages that of
augmented reality and these these ways
of being able to see the evolution of
Earth and the evolution of civilization
and be like hey we are all one we did
all come from one we are stewards I'm
very blessed you know
when you're struggling to survive when
you don't have your house in order and
you're you know when you're you're me
isn't you know stable it's very hard to
see beyond that so this is not like
something you just say okay yeah I want
to go do that you know you kind of have
to get past that basic level of needs
being met and then it is up to you then
it does start to become a choice you
know but until then you know you don't
have it and a lot of the world doesn't
really have that choice because they're
caught in this you know vicious cycle of
survival yeah
and so I don't take any of that for
granted I am very blessed and you know
eternally grateful for the fact that I
can have I can you know be this way
think this way feel this way because
it's not just an option that's why some
people go oh that's crazy that's
ridiculous that does make any sense to
me
when you talk about that's not the way
that this games been designed it's
dog-eat-dog you got to get what's yours
and step on who you need you to get
there and I understand why some people
feel that way because in the world in
which we live you look around that's
kind of what you're taught you know
that's you know what you're shown is you
got to fight for what you want you know
you know because that's you know most of
the examples that you see when you turn
on your television and you know when you
take a look at the world around and and
when you try to live this way normally
then someone takes advantage of you and
then you're like wait what am i doing
you know no good deed goes unpunished
you know and so you get often turned
away from this path many times over
until you eventually say no I just need
to make the right choices and where I
spend my time and who I help and that I
can't necessarily help everyone
because they haven't they still got a
you know they're caught in a loop that
they need to resolve themselves you know
you can't always be there to help
everyone but I you know you there's a
lot of reasons why people may not you
know identify with that and they might
find it you know think that's crazy and
that doesn't make sense and it's not
realistic you know so utopian sort of
mindset if it is really a roll of the
dice that we end up living in such
abundance and privilege with a roof over
our heads running water food all these
all these baked in necessities versus
those that don't then it really inspires
us to help make sure that if it was just
a role that can we can we uplift to make
sure that we can all experience that
privilege that that that together and
make it easier to contemplate the cosmos
to contemplate our expanded awareness
you were teaching me this and this kind
of gets us into the journey you added
into Maslow's hierarchy of needs
internet and financial ability right and
I think that's so cool tell us about
this journey because we listed a bunch
of the things that you're a co-founder
of and that you've been an investor into
but even a movie star in your younger
days as well and it's very interesting
Mighty Ducks and it's very interesting
thinking about you know your journey and
how you ended up living your life and
getting to this point that you're at now
give us this this journey well I mean
how far back do you want to go this life
in this life yeah it started acting I
was a kid in Minnesota and I was blessed
with some success in that area and that
eventually led me out to California and
and then did some more that and I
started when I was you know before I
made any decisions I was you know
you know a couple years old when I
started working and the the first job my
first memory in life takes place on a
set making a commercial for KCRW called
don't let your babies grow up to be
Cowboys and so that led me to California
and my first night in LA was Northridge
earthquake which set my journey in this
weird sort of like it messed up
everything I didn't have money and so I
went out to California for three months
I had a chance to you know my shot to
strike it big or not and you go back
home with your tail between your legs
and that earthquake messed up the entire
market for three months I mean it was
basically a miracle that allowed me to
to book a job that allowed me to have
the budget to be able to stay another
week which then I led to a next job and
then a done job though that but then
about the time I was 14 15 I'm like is
this what I want to do I know this is
what I'm doing and I'm doing very well
at it but am I really an actor and I
told myself no I said I'm an
entrepreneur because I grew up and I was
selling software in like second grade
and building every lemonade stand
business imaginable
and so I was super entrepreneurial you
know buying selling trading baseball
cards magic cards everything I mean I
just did all this stuff all the time and
I was a very avid gamer most people
don't have software in that category of
lemonade stands and trading cards once
where I went to church I went to church
my mother was my mother's a minister and
a bunch of things and I had to go to
like church five days a week and because
my mother was getting her you know
degrees and things and the church next
the building like you know out the back
and you know nearby was a distributor
for like word munchers number of
munchers Oregon Trail all these things
and I would go dumpster diving and you
know pull out all this return sort of
stuff they were fine it's just damaged
box or this or that and everything like
second third grade and I would take him
to school and I'd rent him for a dollar
I'd sell him for 5 if he wanted the box
in the manual and all the things i
mean--can fact then he just installed
his
obviously I was even back in the day
like doing video game rental business
like very very you know and no one had
money they'd have to like ask their
parents for the buck so yeah they're
like pre sell it get the kids to go home
and tell their parents
I can buy educational games but I grew
up in in the movie business and so for
me I always wanted to be the producer
you know I wanted to be the person that
like you know made the movie I didn't
want to be the performer I wanted to be
the person that like puts it together
and you know that was the job that like
that's the person I identified with I
didn't fully appreciate you know what it
took I'm 14 at 15 at the time and then I
just decided like not active anymore and
I quit acting at the height of my career
I was being offered starring roles in
movies which is like one in a million
yeah and I just said I'm not interested
I mean my poor manager and agent and
publicist and all these people because
it's rare that you you know you have
that level of success and if you're the
you know manager if you're the apparatus
around them that's when you get paid and
your scores your age was fifteen fifty
how did this come to you when you were
fifteen this realization that you're an
entrepreneur not an actor yeah you felt
it
yeah well my poor agent and stuff I'm
like they're like they called me up
they're like and I go to remember the
lunch meeting they're like Brock seems
like you're just like you don't want to
do this anymore what's going on you you
struck it big this is the opportunity
this is why you're gonna make all the
money all the good stuff I'm like I just
don't feel it and they're like but you
have to just think about outlook you are
you know millions of people would love
kill for this position you know and you
don't want to do it like not really I'm
not feeling it but then you know I did
one more movie I was offered to star in
this I did two more films after I made
the decision to quit I did a film in
Egypt because the idea of going to live
in Egypt for a few months as a movie
star with all the special access to all
the things it sounded kind of cool so I
got to do that and I got to engrave my
name on the top of the largest pyramid
and all sorts of weird stuff super fun
and then
I wasn't gonna do anything again in my
my agent took me and said Brock I know
you don't want to do any more this but I
like would you be willing to do like
something for charity
it's kind of like your last last movie
Billy Graham is working on this film and
they're looking for a lead for this film
with Michael Biehn and a bunch of
interesting actors and it's a it's you
know obviously this is for the church it
doesn't pay and you'd be the star and
you know whatever whatever would you be
down to do that I'm like yeah because it
seems like it's for a good cause I will
go do that movie and so I I did my last
film for charity for Billy Graham when I
was 16 and then I retired from acting
and I went and tried to become a
producer and that was really really hard
and I didn't succeed at that but I mean
we made a couple of little like films as
kids with friends and then and then I
got into media I got into tech what
happened is I started seeing the
internet you know taking off and started
seeing you know people raising money and
building companies and I'm like I'm
entrepreneurial I know tak I'm an actor
I can pretend to do this and so I got
into I got into doing that and so I was
again very blessed ended up raising
eighty eight million dollars when I was
17 18 in the internet 1.0 phase to build
what you think of today is like YouTube
and Hulu and Netflix we were the first
ones you know we've created words like
webisode we were the ones creating the
format of how video would eventually be
distributed over the internet and then I
also played lots of games you know which
then led me to game currencies you know
specifically things like world of
warcraft and so I identified in 1999
that people playing these games in these
persistent worlds were accumulating
digital or intangible assets and you
know it seems obvious now but back then
the idea that these things would have
value was crazy you know people would be
like are you kidding me you're selling a
virtual sword you're selling gold you're
doing all this stuff why would anyone
pay money for a virtual sword that's not
real I go well you play golf right and
they're like yeah I go do you like to
use good golf clubs or bad golf clubs
they're like good golf clubs obviously I
go
because that's how you choose to spend
your discretionary time and your
discretionary income right your
expendable income I go if you chose to
play World of Warcraft with your free
time wouldn't you want a good sword over
a bad sword doesn't that improve your
game experience and they're like okay
that makes sense I go that's what it is
you know people human behavior is the
same whether it's in the analog world or
the digital world you know the same
thing still motivate us it's you know
utility or social status or you know
something right we all want to increase
our compute because we all are on these
devices all the time so we want the
better technologies that give us better
utility yeah yeah yeah so that's that I
got into the games business when the
Internet bubble burst because we went
bankrupt like everybody else 99 plus
percent of companies in 2000 and I went
and pursued game currencies and started
making a market for virtual currencies
in games like Second Life and world
Warcraft and we built a supply chain of
400,000 people in China that would play
games professionally to mine digital
currencies we were PayPal's largest
customer for years we were Google's
largest advertiser for a moment we
launched a leap a you know so I got very
deep into gaming intangible assets and
currencies and cross-border payment
systems and emerging markets and you
know creating jobs and places like China
because and the reason why people play
games by the hundreds of thousands is
you could make more money playing games
than you could as a doctor or a lawyer
for a moment there and that motivated
people and I needed lots of currency and
so I had to teach the world how to play
games to make money and China was the
place I went to do that these are all
these pieces are now fitting together
into understanding who you who you
became because all the way from your
acting and producing and to the tech
sector and to the the gaming all these
pieces on especially virtual currencies
that people were like it's crazy that
you even went all the way to be part of
the launch of Olli pay which is now one
of the largest payment systems in China
Fletch and released I do need to release
the contract because it's just
good so we were PayPal's largest driver
of customers right after eBay but eBay
wasn't an individual merchant we were
PayPal's largest merchants for years a
project IG he was the name of their
credit card payment direct payment
system which was code named after us I
was on their advisory board for whatever
all the payment stuff and so in China
because we were the main company doing
all the cross-border payments Taobao and
Alibaba which is the company they
produced Olli pay you know who you know
is jak mom they came and they said you
know Brock we we need you to use us yeah
because they were a start-up with no
traction they go you're the person your
business drives all of it all customer
adoption people your industry is
basically what will make us so what do
we have to do to work with you I said I
am I would love to help you but I have
hundreds of thousands of people in China
playing games to sell me currency that I
sell to you know the rest of the world
if I the reason why they all sell to me
is because they don't have access to
cross-border payment systems and they
don't have you know foreign language
customer service if I enabled
cross-border payments and yeah pushed my
entire supply chain to you that would
kind of probably be really bad for my
business and as much as I'd love to help
you I I can't do that
I brought these reasons they're like
well what do we have to do well if you
give me an exclusive in perpetuity on
digital assets I would do it and they're
like okay and so I signed that contract
which they violated shortly thereafter
which would have been had I lived
backwards I have a multi billion dollar
claim which I looked at for a moment and
then I i-i've you suing people is like
going backwards in time instead I should
just release the contract and tell the
story because it's it's an interesting
one
whoa and then this journey led it makes
sense with hundreds of thousands
millions of people playing already in
virtual worlds earning like you said the
best sort of of items in order to use in
those worlds and also being able to
trade then the currencies not only in
that virtual world but in the outside
world as so you couldn't go in and now
this slowly gets you more and more
interested in digital currency you were
also you can get us get us any into the
into the thick of things now with all
the over the last five years with all of
the companies that you and well yeah so
eventually Bitcoin right happens and my
opinion of Bitcoin in the early days was
that I said that Bitcoin or something
like it is the future I just don't know
if the future is now or 25 years from
now it's a market timing thing I learned
with broadband and video that you know
just because something is obvious future
idea like people are gonna watch videos
on their computers and their televisions
are eventually gonna become networked
and have internet connections and things
that just because you're right doesn't
mean you'll be successful there's a
thing called market timing you know we
were 10 years before the broadband was
you know there to a point that you could
do this feasibly and so my thesis of
Bitcoin is when does it take off so it
wasn't until 2012 where I started to see
a critical mass of adoption where I'm
like alright future is now it's
happening and that's when I dropped
every other thing that I was doing I had
a lot of game businesses and other
things and I just started wrapping up
everything else I was working on so that
I could move full time into this space
and more or less do nothing else and so
that's essentially what happened I got
very deep into Bitcoin mining and then
starting a company every 45 to 60 days I
was essentially operating as an
incubator for a while and then I started
to many companies that there's only so
many things that you can manage
effectively or poorly and I got to the
point that I couldn't imagine anything
anything more even poorly I had spread
myself too thin
and I went but I still want to do more
there must be more to do and so then I
started a venture capital firm the first
venture fund in the space called
blockchain capital because I'm like well
I can't keep doing more things as a
founders so the only way that I can get
more exposure is as a cheque writer so I
just need to go fund everybody and you
know put money into fifth the next 50
companies that I think are interesting
and so I had an interesting sort of ride
throughout that piece like the the
notable stuff that was exciting is you
know I ended up being one of the
founding board members or cofounders a
master coin which was the first ICO and
so we you know invented the ICO
blockchain capital the first venture
fund in the space tether which is where
we put the first real world asset on the
blockchain and that's doing now like
five to ten some days not twenty billion
a day but you know call it ten billion a
day it's doing you know three and a half
trillion you know a year you know to ten
trillion a year of transactions I mean
these are it's getting into numbers that
are like trillion is that really double
check it is those kinds of numbers and
this is because the real world items
that are that you really want to be able
to put on a decentralized distributed
ledger are very expensive
well we invented a kind of category
called stable coins crypto currencies
are volatile and so with tether we put
the US dollar on the blockchain so it's
literally just a digital dollar backed
up by an actual dollar and so sometimes
if you think the price of Bitcoin is
going to go down what you do is you just
convert your Bitcoin into tether or USD
we call us tea and then the price goes
down and then you buy back in so we
created the mechanism by which you could
stay in a crypto currency but have fiat
money and so the crypto currency markets
really needed you know a stable
instrument to be able to you know in-out
in-out yeah otherwise anytime you wanted
to sell you to wait a week for a wire to
hit a bank account and then to send it
back a week and pay prese fees it also
enabled crypto exchanges that didn't
have access to banking and payment rails
you know that didn't have the licensing
to be able to offer
money it gave them the same tools that
the coin basis have it gave them it
allowed them to have US dollar
essentially deposits because you had
crypto to crypto exchanges and then you
had crypt at a Fiat exchanges what it
does it gave Fiat capability essentially
to fiat being a term for government
issued to all the exchanges so it was a
huge huge hit I remember at the time
everybody in the industry because there
were only about a hundred of us at the
time probably building things that
mattered thought it was the dumbest idea
ever why would we ever want a digital
dollar on blockchain I mean we're all
here because we don't believe in that
stuff I'm like you needed a tether yeah
yeah you needed to tether the real world
to this world to make it all start to
work better I said well let's see how it
goes you might be right but I think that
you know this matters me take a look at
the developing world you know because I
spent you know a lot of people would
criticize me in the early days like
Bitcoin is bad you know because if you
read the news at the time every headline
was sensational it was like it's only
for drugs or it's only for an illegal
gambling or you know yeah you know or
it's a scam you know there was no one
writing positive articles about Bitcoin
in 2012 or 13 not many and you had to go
far and deep and wide to find positive
statements the media was really just
sensationalizing the negative aspects of
it interestingly enough one could say
similarly to when we were initially
developing a unit of exchange thousands
of years ago figuring out well why does
this one have any meaning or purpose
well I don't this village door this
civilization does not agree that it does
not so this is another sort of bubbling
up of similar yeah the same story right
broader distribution now um and and the
world changes quickly
everything's accelerating and so you
know I get criticized like you know
sometimes people cuz you know some news
stories or something would come out
about Bitcoin I'd be out of the
restaurant and some would be like or
they'd overhear us talking about it and
they and someone it'll be like Bitcoin
Bitcoin yeah well I I know all about
that and I'm like you do and they're
like yeah something you know always try
to be really confrontational start a
fight almost and they're you know I'm
like you know I'm always trying to be
engaging you know playing a little bit
of a river of psychology and it's like
okay and so like well I should I want
Bitcoin and I'd be like you shouldn't
like what do you mean I shouldn't take
it well it's not for you but what do you
mean not for me I'd be like well you
have a bank account and they'd be like
yeah and I go well you have a piece of
plastic in your pocket that lets you
conveniently pay for things and they'd
be like yeah and I go and you have a
rule of law here that's here in theory
to protect you and often well and you
probably have faith in the system and of
the two hundred currencies in the world
you've got one that everybody wants more
of and you probably take all of that for
granted most of the world 2/3 of the
population of the planet is unbanked or
underbanked seventy million Americans
are on banked or underbanked but you're
not one of them and so I see why it's
very easy for you not to understand how
the other half lives
but if you go south of the border if you
go look at Africa or Southeast Asia
you know those people don't have those
basic needs met back to the Maslow's
hierarchy of needs sort of stuff today
you need these things we have tools that
allow us to have opportunity in life a
majority the population the planet do
not have those tools to live a life of
abundance to live a life to allow us to
think about you know how we can choose
to spend our time you know and one of
the things that this sector is doing is
its democratizing the global financial
system in a way where every human being
on the planet will have equal access
that doesn't mean equal lives but
hopefully at least equal tools which
then eventually can lead to
opportunities so on and so forth given a
sufficient amount of time and so and and
the people that benefit the most are
obviously the least fortunate today and
so it's uh you know this was like the
conversation I'd have with people is
it's like why would you want a digital
dollar I go well in Venezuela you know
they all want dollars right now and if
you had a way of getting them digital
dollars you know the Venezuelan people
would be benefiting greatly you know so
there should be demand for this stuff
around the world everybody wants you as
dollars let's tokenize it and send it to
africa and so far it seems to be kind of
working the stories that you illustrate
are very important for us to to become a
little bit more humble by by fully
getting behind the eyes of when we don't
have access to Internet when we don't
have access to financial tools that we
don't have those frequently available at
our tool belts to end up really giving
us an ability to self actualize and an
experience even further self
transcendence that that that can
sometimes that can sometimes inhibit the
flow that we want of actualization and
transcendence so I really really think
that that example is crucial especially
since us more than 50 percent of
humanity is unbanked or underbanked
which is so much then okay so then we're
talking about banking people giving
people an opportunity and equal
opportunity to be able to participate in
the global financial markets start
businesses do very innate enable their
creative potential to flourish so then
the you also have another quote about
the underlying technology so that's kind
of on digital currency side things then
you have a quote about the underlying
technology which is this blockchain
technology yeah you have you you believe
that that's completely replacing the
Internet not somewhat synergistic well
it's it's synergistic I don't think the
blockchain is gonna replace the Internet
I think the Internet is going to be
replaced by something new a new Internet
yeah okay and one of the components of
that new Internet is blockchain okay but
it's not the soul the blockchain doesn't
replace the Internet the blockchain is
essentially a ledger and a security
protocol and a governance system and a
very resilient
you know decentralized system that it
creates immutability in a bunch of other
stuff but that's those are civility some
of the core tenants of why the system's
gonna be upgraded and that the main
thing I'd say is that the internet
itself today is broken it's yes the
internet is broken but why is it broken
because that sounds like a crazy
statement when the internet was first
being designed it was known how to
secure the Internet at least from a [ __ ]
table cryptography perspective the
problem is there the computer processing
power at the time wasn't sufficient to
do it and let's just say the powers that
be didn't want it that way and so the
internet was designed by designed to be
insecure to you know have backdoors and
things and so we've essentially built up
the entire internet on a faulty
foundation it's like building on the
sand right you know you're building you
know buildings that are not built on
solid foundations have problems over
time and the entire internet has been
built on a faulty foundation so what
you're seeing is you're reading about
more and more hacks and information
being accessed and your information
being accessed and you know and you're
only seeing bits and pieces of it you
know these problems are becoming greater
and greater and greater I mean there's
great job opportunities in Internet
security you know the companies the
internet security companies they're out
there have more business than they can
handle because this problem is becoming
that prevalent and now you have
nation-states that are providing
state-sponsored hacking there are
countries that allow people in their
country to hack the government condones
it they won't arrest you if you go rob
Americans on the internet they give you
a high-five you get a bonus from the
government I mean I mean it the problem
is you know accelerating there for a
change is gonna be needed we're gonna
have to go through an upgrading of
systems and that over the next ten years
I believe is going to happen slowly and
new Internet's going to emerge it's
gonna look just like the one you use
today you won't even notice anything
changed it's just the underlying
architecture and stack is going to
change in the same way that you don't
need to know what's inside of a phone to
be able to use it you know that you know
you know what how to use it and you know
what the benefits are you know it's
still gonna look like websites it's
still gonna look like apps but the
underlying infrastructure and the tech
stack is gonna be different than the
blockchain is providing the security
layer
so so so let's let's let's double click
in though a little bit deeper because
when you know when we say things like we
use a piece of technology and that
technology we are kind of a little black
box relationship with it as long as we
can double click into the plumbing and
understand if we so choose to is very
important to inspire more people to get
behind it just keep building it up keep
advancing the tech well that's our our
space is all open source yes we're an
open source movement you know which by
nature means you can come learn how it
works if you're curious and you want to
learn yes yes ok so then you know let's
let's because we can double click into
the plumbing of the internet like you
were describing let's say version 1.0
and see that the security protocols
there are just issues with the
fundamental structures let's say I first
built on top of sand that have been
making the security companies what they
are today with the mass amounts of
volume of companies that they want to
figure out oh how do we keep say
everything's secure and private cetera
so my question then would be then is
then the current foundation of the
Internet can it be augmented in an its
existing way to add the blockchain
technologies into it or is is this what
u.s. is is the yes please speak on this
yeah so it's it's a different enough
architecture that each the everything
will have to be rebuilt you know kind of
on the back end but that doesn't mean
you'll notice it and it doesn't mean it
all happens at once right you're gonna
be seeing new entrants enter the market
and you're gonna see incumbents and any
you know anytime you have this radical
change it looks like when the internet
first emerged
you know when the internet came along it
disrupted all business to some degree
some analog businesses that weren't on
the internet went on the internet and
they're still around today you know some
new companies that said hey we're gonna
build a bookstore online Amazon replace
most of the bookstores and these are
these are these sort of jump-ball
opportunities you know that don't come
along very often and historically but
they seem to be happening more and more
often these days as we're going through
this sort of accelerated change but yeah
we're looking
another one of those types of moments in
time you know and we'll the you know
Facebook's of the world you know upgrade
in time or will something else come
along that might replace it you know
from a decentralization perspective you
know if Facebook were to be usurped or
Instagram by a lot of blockchain version
of it and Facebook is working on this so
it's kind of a relevant one how would it
be different the main thing is we're
already all using call it Instagram or
Facebook or whatever system you want to
say so would have to be substantially
better because Facebook's gonna make
that migration and this will be an
interesting one to watch yeah if we were
going to use a new system and based upon
everything we feel and you know what we
know today it would have to we'd have to
own our own data first of all you know
right now we don't even know where our
data is all over the place you know
people are coming into our most you know
these tech overlords are coming into our
most private places taking our taking
our most you know private of things and
then selling it you know without our
knowledge so you know one of the big
things it's likely going to change as a
result of this is you know us taking
back our data and that doesn't mean that
data can't be sold but it'll get sold
with our consent or consent like moving
into a world of consent right now people
are coming in you know in you know
violating us in our private places
without our consent and that's not okay
yes yes yes it's not the non-consensual
asymmetry and knowledge about data our
own private data there is everything
from the tiny little devices we have
inside of our homes all the way to our
biometric data and that is we are not in
control like having little valves and
letting the data flow to whichever
destinations we will consensually agree
for it to flow so that and all consent
because I want the benefits of some of
these things but I want to decide who I
give it to which businesses I want to
know who it I want to say okay I think
that group operates with integrity yes
I'll let them have my data you know and
I'll cook it paid for that data or all
benefit from the service from that data
but I want to decide if if if
we were given the ability to flick on
the let my location data flow so Google
Maps can continue having its I would
because I'm gonna use it I believe over
90%
yeah well would still say yes and then
the and will and will and we'll see so
now the question would be then how does
the it gets structured as you know as a
visionary I know you keep explaining
that there are gonna be lots of
different like innovations that are made
in the space and then humans will decide
with their with their finances and their
attention which ones they want to pick
what does what does a really powerful
vision of what of what it could be look
like to you well I think in the future
we own our own data you know we consent
you know to who gets access to that data
and we're gonna do that either because
we want to make money off our data
because it's we know it's very valuable
we just normally don't get any of the
money you know normally you know the
Facebook's and the Google's take all of
the money from for our data and we don't
even get a piece of our own data yeah
normally you know yeah you go work a job
and you get some of the fruits of your
labor and your boss and the company you
know takes a piece of it to but you
don't really get something you know
today we all get nothing and we don't
even consent to where it goes I mean
it's I think that that's one of the big
changes that's gonna happen I think the
world you know just on every level it's
we're gonna move into a world of
transparency you know where we know
what's going on you know right now most
of us are walking around in the dark you
know basically the lights are coming on
and are you okay with that being in a
global surveillance style of
transparency well I mean that this is
where you know things get very you know
interesting and how you know how global
surveillance it is and in that
transparency is it come you know every
you know everything that everybody does
or do you have pseudo anonymity you know
I tend to believe in you know if you can
say okay I don't want this data to be
shared and its private and we're gonna
build systems around things where
privacy is very important I'm one that's
gonna opt in
for privacy around certain aspects of
life you know I'm not gonna let anyone
monetize my bedroom for example you know
it what I talk about in my bedroom with
my wife or you know things of that
nature sorry that room is off-limits you
know for sure and then I have the
strongest security protocols around that
but then versus this episode being
online you would let not only be let
flow as many places as possible yeah I
mean certain things are gonna be and but
these are the decisions that I don't get
to make we collectively are going to
make right you know technology is
technology it doesn't make these sorts
of decisions it doesn't have morals
right we decide you know the outcomes of
these systems in the world that we're
gonna collectively create is going to be
determined by the quality of the people
that build it and the intentions by
which they do it that's right
which is why you know this is kind of a
call to action you know for the awfulest
knows yeah but our future is going to be
determined by those of us that are
building it so let's make sure the
people that are doing the work right now
the builders and the early adopters are
doing it with the right intentions
because we are co-creating it now and so
that question yes I are the things that
keep me up at night you know you know
and there's a certain amount of like
it's back to governance or government
right what do we collectively believe is
the right amount of privacy versus
transparency that's needed and you know
you know so that we are you know
generally what you do in your home and
what you do that only affects your life
is none of my business
as long as you're not harming others but
when you start to go into the public
spaces where you impact the lives of
others then this is where the rules
start to you know matter more and more
and in those spaces
you know what pride what privileges do
you have and these are the discussions
that we collectively have to have so
that we can collectively come to the
best conclusion and make the best
decisions you know I'm I spend a lot of
time educating governments around the
world you know which you know a lot of
the early crypto people are kind of more
an artistic or you know I I believe in I
believe that I want to create a you know
not here to like destroy systems I'm not
here to try and lead a revolution you
know my perfect outcome is this is an
evolutionary event a win-win event where
the incumbents and the new entrants you
know collectively can win clearly that
can't happen everywhere but that is the
ideology and the vision that I want to
sell people if you choose that you don't
want to participate obviously you're
gonna eventually lose if this does
happen right so bring people to the
table and naturally the first reaction
of incumbents governments or anybody
that's you know if you're in power your
first reaction to something new is fear
something that might threaten you fear
but how do you concur fear with
knowledge with information with
hopefully an R and D aspects of the new
technology with information and so if
you want governments or incumbents to
make good decisions you need
well-informed governments and it takes
people to know how to explain it
yeah correct you know and so ii-i've all
I've signed up for the mission of like
yeah try to explain this to people
because guess what once they start to
understand it they start to understand
how that future is beneficial to all of
us you know people start saying well
actually I kind of like that future I
want to help enable that future I want
to and I'm gonna do that by
experimenting with it with that sort of
R&D type of budget yeah yeah we're very
grateful that you've been going and
teaching people about the transition to
the new decentralized infrastructures
that hopefully the blossom a much more
actualized civilization and there's a
couple interesting keys to what you're
just saying about you you use the words
crypto maximalism and chain agnosticism
oh yeah which I really like those too a
lot and so it's it's it's letting all of
the all humans go at play all these old
incumbents as well as the new ones go at
play figure out what is going to be the
best codes for us to pick up and use in
in the future and then this is a lot of
what these companies that you've
co-founded are are doing is they're
pushing the paradigms in these in these
departments but now I want I want you to
explain to us there's so much
happening across the world with these
new you know these new temps of futurism
and technologies that that maximize
potential you're you're spearheading one
yourself as well in San Juan in Puerto
Rico and when when I'm learning about
this I'm you know you're walking down
the streets and people are like oh it's
mr. Bitcoin you know and things like
that and so but you're very playful with
the community in terms of your ability
to realize that like you wanna you're
turning some of the older thing into
some of the museum / freemasons halls
this type of stuff into community
centers founding banks eco resorts
you're sort of starting this new
civilization there so teach us about
about what that exactly entails well two
to two parts to that one as you talked
about sort of chain agnosticism and
stuff it which is a very important one
that I like to get out there because
what tends to happen is I'm a Bitcoin
person I'm an etherium person I'm on all
of these things people but you get a lot
of people that are call it newcomers to
the industry or have a very vested
interest in a specific outcome and so
what happens is they're like oh Bitcoin
good everything else bad or aetherium is
good to win and everything else is bad
and you get a lot of this me against you
left versus right my chain is better
than your chain my coins better than
your coin this maximalism is north which
is normally around vested interests is
it reminds me of religious
fundamentalism hey we've learned over
thousands of years that's not good and
so I'm always very quick to point out
I'm training now stick I don't play on
any team and I don't care
I play in all teams that is as long as I
think that the people behind it and the
project looks like it has good
intentions and it might make the world a
better place as long as those things are
there I'm here to cheer you along and be
helpful to the extent I can serve you to
because I don't care who wins as long as
we make the world a better place and so
you know keep an open mind we're
building open source systems hopefully
with open minds and open hearts and that
means that you might have a project that
looks like my project
and I thought a lot of entrepreneurs
this early on to seems like no Brock I
can't sit at this dinner with you no but
those two people I'm like why they what
they're working on the same thing
they're my competitor I'm like your
competitor what does that mean and you
know I get to and I'd basically take
them to the the thing that I said that
person that you're threatened by
understands you more than almost anyone
in the world they share your exact
passion your exact focus they get up
every day trying to do the same thing as
you but you're afraid of that person you
don't want to meet them this is the
person that gets you better than almost
anyone more than your partner I mean
your wife or husband or lover boy from
this that that's someone that probably
if you can get past the fear yeah
correct your best friend why are you
here we talked about trying to make the
world a better place you should be
helping each other what you might figure
out is you decide you want to merge and
work together
yeah or you have different views of how
the world is going to change and then
it's an a/b test and you should be
cheering them on and they should be
cheering you on because if either of you
win everybody wins and maybe you should
be swapping some of your stock or tokens
with theirs so that you don't care which
of you wins you're just taking two
different a/b tests into the market you
know it stopped it stopped being this
fear-based sort of thing and start
realizing that you have a lot in common
and that's a very interesting
perspective to what some people call
like you can take an example of like
lyft and uber into the market and and
think if the stocks were swapped 5050 if
the co-founders were collaborating on
the computer vision for the vehicles and
advancing the autonomous systems faster
and not poaching talent from each other
all these different things the scarcity
mindset versus abundance it's kind of
one of the key nuances to that yeah and
realizing we're an industry that has you
know you know at the time you know 0.01%
market share I'm like why are you
worried about fighting over someone
that's got a thousand customers and
you've got five hundred there's billions
to be had like really stop fighting with
each other there's a whole big world out
there it's like the race for monopoly
but then the end
potentially not yeah yes so I spent a
lot of time on that and so you know III
try to like be a good guide you know I
try to be a ship mentor and advisor you
know I helped her a helping hand which
is a bunch what eventually led me down
to Puerto Rico you know I came to this
sort of when I was blessed with having
made a few dollars more than I had made
or lost in the past and I'm really good
at making and losing fortunes I've been
blessed in that regard mostly because I
don't care that much and you know I
started to really kind of ask myself
around you know what are the ways that
you know you know people measure their
own success what is the KPI or the Kate
you know create key performance
indicators you use to measure your
success you know what makes people happy
and these words of things and it's like
I don't want to measure my success by
you know how much money I have in these
things as people start too much Bitcoin
you have how much money did you make
it's like who cares you know I I like
going to places like Burning Man where
there isn't even money yeah these are
not the things that motivate me you know
and it's like okay so what what does
motivate me how do I wanted like to find
that and I had been taught a lot of
classes at the same deal arity
University and really like some of the
things I heard Jason Silva say over the
years and I don't know who coined the
term but it was one of those two because
they've all started singing around the
same time which is that a billionaire is
not someone with a billion dollars but
someone that positively impacts the
lives of a billion people and I had
heard this line and I'm just like that
is the thing that resonates with me and
so you know I started like you know
making this part of my stick I get
probably most of the credit for it now
cuz I've probably blown up the phrase
but I didn't invent it I didn't coin it
it's a very beautiful phrase and we have
a we have an asset of you giving a talk
using the slide of the new billionaire
positively impacts lives of billions of
people I love that yeah and so because I
what would happen is I felt this
responsibility when the crypto market in
2016 and 17 all of a sudden all these
young people are making all this money
having more money doesn't always make
you a better person I think it actually
probably does more often than not the
opposite and so I felt I didn't give my
talk if you've ever watched any of my
speeches I almost rarely talk about
anything I've accomplished or anything
I've done unless there's like a story
you know what why this what that you're
getting into something long form I take
the time when I've been if you're taking
the time to listen to what I have to say
I want to impart knowledge I want to
impart insight I want to impart you know
things that are like elevate your
thinking and so when I go have
conversations the crypto community it's
like all right we're in a bull market
everyone's making tons of money oh god
this is not gonna be good for most of
them so let's start telling them
something they need to hear it's not
about the money I know you're all
getting rich for the first time in your
life this is not a good thing keep your
feet on the ground you know and so these
are the types of things I'm always think
about what does the market need right
now you know when we go into a bear
market then they need some cheerleading
you know in the bull market they need
people pulling their feet back to earth
you know as I like to say bull markets
produce bull [ __ ] bear markets bear
fruit you know you know when the markets
are up and everyone's making money it
attracts all the worst qualities it
attracts all the worst people we kind of
saw that a little bit in the last couple
of years and then what happens is
fortunately the market goes through the
cycle of a cleanse it purges out all of
the people that are showing up with the
wrong intentions and then the market
tightens back up again the core group of
true believers real builders are what's
left and then the market has another
swing back and we go through these
cycles yeah necessary purges I'm glad
that you know I I like bear markets
because that's when the real work is
done that's when you look around the
room and everybody you see are like the
right people they're there because the
intention is to build a transformational
technology yeah they're not just there
for the quick buck you know they're not
there just figure out you know how to
you know in those bull markets it's very
hard you know that's when I start to
check out it's like alright let's wait
for the next purge and then I'll come
back and like you know and the only
thing I do it during those bull markets
is I try to talk some sense into people
and so when I say I check out I realized
wherever I go was going for a little
while interesting people super here
would show up from all over the world
and I'm like well if this is the case
let's see I'm in New York okay people
will come here and people just jump on
planes I'm in London people jump on
planes I'm in Hong Kong people jump from
Plains I'm like if wherever I go really
interesting people show up and then
people want to start companies nearby
wherever I'm living like you know people
pack up homes and like Oh Rock you're
gonna be living here this is where you
spend much time and also neighborhood
starts just filling up and the houses in
the neighborhood are all getting bought
by interesting people that you know
share more and more of these mindsets
I'm like I need to run an experiment if
I'm becoming a bit of a nexus point you
know individually and I can live
anywhere where should I live should I
live where I want to live or should I go
somewhere that could use some help you
know should I go somewhere where my
being there might actually have an
impact and this is an experiment it was
a crazy idea and everybody's making
money on crypto I'm like all right I'm
just gonna go disappear and I wanna go
to Puerto Rico where literally there was
not almost nothing happening that was
relevant to me in terms of opportunity
cost it was as big a sacrifice as I
could possibly make at the height of
that the highest point in my life like
my acting career I walked away and I
went and said let's go see what we can
do in Puerto Rico with the intention to
help positively impact the communities
of Puerto Rico yeah it was right after
Hurricane Maria you know so following
the hurricane you know everybody there
were three and a half million people in
Puerto Rico it went down to three
million and of the half-a-million people
that left who do you think left it's the
people with the means to leave the
people with the intellectual capital the
human capital the financial capital the
spiritual capital those with the means
to leave do you know I'm sorry all right
well that's a brain drain how do you
combat a brain drain with a brain game
so let's go see if I go down there and
you know beat a little drum or something
you know will people come and will they
start to build will they start to do
positive things and impact the community
positively can we help in some way can
we contribute in some way and so it was
an experiment it's still in its infancy
it's only been a year and a half but
about a thousand interesting people have
moved that
you know those talents and you know you
now have lots of startup accelerators
and incubators and co-working facilities
and co-living facilities you know you
have angels and mentors and you know
kind of all the stuff all the the stuff
that allows a startup ecosystem to exist
like this place has so abundantly it's
there now and there were six startups
that raised money last year like in the
last six months like a million bucks
each that never happened before
Puerto Rico when you walk into the top
Silicon Valley VC firms when you mention
Puerto Rico they're like oh yeah that's
a blockchain hub
how did Puerto Rico get a spot on the
map in tech and innovation yes it was
not an obvious place but what happened
is Puerto Rico is now on the short list
of places that are considered to be a
hub of innovation which what were the
odds of that happening but and then
teach us about the way that then the
community of the three million
inhabitants of Puerto Rico are being
integrated into this block chain
technology explosion so that it's not
obviously well the first thing is a lot
of them have heard about it now yeah it
made the news and it's been part of the
conversation and the first reaction like
I said in your first reaction typically
is to fear that what you don't
understand yeah but Puerto Ricans
understand decentralization and
resiliency better than you know most
almost everyone another couple of
interesting data points in the context
of Puerto Rico Puerto Rico has more
bachelor degrees per capita than
anywhere in the United States interests
the Puerto Rico has more artists per
capita than anywhere in the United
States Puerto Rico is filled with talent
yeah yeah the abundance of talent what
they've been lacking isn't is its
opportunity because you know people keep
leaving because there's not enough
opportunity you know so what if we can
start to change that mindset what if we
can start showing people opportunities
what if you know startup you know what
if being an entrepreneur I mean if you
were a Puerto Rican that wanted to be an
entrepreneur you had to move what if we
can bring a few angels down here some
mentors some capital you know and you
know all of a sudden there's ten Puerto
Rican startups or a hundred Porto Rican
startups when you're graduating from
college and you or you want to or
whatever stage you are in your life
you want to be an entrepreneur it's now
an option there because the tools are
present back to like not having the
payment systems not having these things
there's basic tools that are needed to
do certain things you know what we have
is we're a very small group of people
but we bring some of the tools that can
get the ball rolling right while
simultaneously bringing the tools to
help the artists and entrepreneurs there
flourish and understand new technologies
leapfrog all that good stuff though
potentially the ones that are maybe
sliding off and unable to maybe afford
some of the new rates and stuff need to
be integrated as well
yeah we're not driving up prices of
anything I mean prices are continuing to
probably go down pretty much
systematically there I mean there still
it's a process you know before Puerto
Rico's tourism is way off all sorts of
stuff it's you know it still has a long
way to go and like for example you know
technology is you know call it core to
my toolkit so I can this is where I can
be helpful with barely making any effort
at all but it's not what I spend my time
on in Puerto Rico you know I try to
think about the big macro issues you
know the thing that I lose sleep over
constantly and back to like calls to
action Puerto Rico only has two to three
weeks of food very little food is grown
on the island almost all of the food is
important even though it has some of the
most fertile soil imaginable and so if
like Miami got hit by a category five
storm and the supply chains got impacted
like this is I lose sleep every night I
want to go figure out how to farm and
how to do you know biodynamic organic
how to fund and finance all sorts of
co-op systems I want I want to help
Porto Rico farm with its AG and forestry
well it was back to food resilience and
Puerto Ricans understand the importance
of resilience having gone through the
storm we know Puerto Rico can handle you
know some meaningful amount of time
without electricity
but Puerto Rico probably can't go very
long without food yeah like anywhere
food security food security is the thing
that I mean like it so like if you're if
you're into farming and like you're
you're you're a superhero that
understands how to do this stuff and
you're like not sure what's going on in
your life you know here's your call that
you know come you know come help teach
and plant some seeds you know grow some
healthy food locally so that you know
you know the foods mostly imported it's
from California it doesn't even make any
sense yeah yeah historical is because of
sugar cane and that the sugar Barons and
the plantations all that all the
original farming is torn up and it was
replaced kind of stuff your your
fascination with with what you're doing
there is is one of the inspirational
pieces that hopefully people from around
the world can then latch on to and try
and help develop and give opportunity
for people to shine in new new new new
ways of thinking I like I like what what
well I'm excited to see what ends up
evolving from that and how these pockets
can evolve around the world moving in
that direction what what we just pulled
up here where Ron just pulled up we have
a chest ahed Rijn here yes and that's
that there's two shapes here because
this is not just a chesty hydron so what
is a chesty hydron a chesty hydron is a
sacred geometric shape this sacred
geometric shape was only rediscovered or
discovered you know first time that
we're aware of in a very long time at
least in the year 2000 by Frank Chester
who lives right here in Mill Valley
Frank Chester is a math professor art
professor and you know he spends his
whole life finding and playing with
geometric shapes and he discovered this
seven sided piece of sacred geometry so
you have like your five platonic solids
and this is moving up in the numbers and
it's the sacred geometric shape of the
heart our heart basically is a chest a
Hedra and when it pumps this is the
shape that it's producing and the blood
that flows through our body actually
spins in the shape if you spin a chest
to ijen it becomes a bell that's
essentially it's an acoustic it's a you
know all these things have resonance and
sounds that they connect with it's all
in vibration as I like to say the free
or the freaks can see in the frequency
but all sacred geometry has a duality
and so the second shape that you're
seeing here is what's known as the de
Decca tria which is the sacred geometric
of the heart and it should come as no
surprise that the earth fits perfectly
and the duality of the heart is the
earth and it also duality goes you can
keep going downward meaning the heart
fits perfectly in the earth and so the
chesty hedron's sits inside of planet
Earth and it rotates on exactly this
shape and there's some pretty crazy
stuff it's worth looking this up Frank
Chester go watch some YouTube videos if
this like touches if there's this is a
rabbit hole for anyone that in the
sacred geometry you want you want to
look at it which is also interesting
because if you take the word heart and
you take the letter H and move it to the
very end it becomes earth it's just odd
how these dualities you know kind of all
line up so perfectly yeah and so we
chose the chest ahed Rijn as the logo
for us yeah so that's the EOS logo it's
you know it's not just a cool logo
totally has a lot of meaning yeah but
well everything you'll notice that we do
you know is we try to have layers yes
and layer yes yes yes lots of meaning
interesting this this we're removing of
a veil with some of the sacred geometry
conversation and I like to say piercing
it
yeah piercing the veil yeah Bernardo
Gunther likes to say that as well we
like him a lot you're seeing that veil
well or if you know like the Knights
Templar purse of all means to pierce the
veil it's a person ball that finds the
Holy Grail to bring the light to the
world interesting these are the layers
again the layers next time we'll have to
speak more on what you know what exactly
is going on with piercing the veil and
remaining in these flow States some of
the stuff on plant medicines we're
excited to unpack that with you on a
future episode it's so interesting
hearing you hearing that you like to
walk around with this speaker blasting
Charlie Chaplin's the Great Dictator I
don't want to rule anyone I should like
to help everyone greed has poisoned
men's souls this sort of this mentality
of what was what was communicated to us
so long ago that is still so relevant
today that message is is very very cool
and I'm glad you picked that all right
let's sum what's real
on our on our simulation questions all
right we like to ask our guests just a
couple questions on the way out the
first question we like to ask is are we
alone in the cosmos are we alone in the
cosmos
well I can't point to any you know
specific absolute evidence to you know
wait on this conclusively but I'm
convinced that we are not alone but
that's a subjective opinion you know
yeah and where does the not alone lie
for you I do not think that life solely
exists on this planet but I also don't
think that we're really from this planet
I mean I believe our souls our celestial
I believe our souls are not of any where
we happen to our souls happen to be in a
vessel here on earth soar earthlings I
like to call this our earth suits but
you know the universe is the universe
you know this just happens to be a
planet within it where our souls are you
know hanging out and you know vessels
and then the the the process of going
into an earth suit and then what we do
before and after that what are you what
are your thoughts about what happens
before you enter the earth suit after
well I you know I normally don't talk
about these things so so publicly but I
think it's I think it's a good thing to
think about I mean this is these
existential questions about religion and
you know where and what and who do we
come from you know I believe we choose
our bodies I believe we kind of choose
our missions and then you know you see
what we do but because there's lessons
to be learned yes there are lots of I
believe that you know we're here to
learn something we're here to grow and
you know we may be here multiple times
this may not be the only call it you
know if this were a video game or a
simulation I don't believe this is a
simulation or a game it is a game just
not a video game it's the great game the
great game the game of life there's a
lot to learn there's a lot to level up
yeah but it's it's about that it's about
leveling up and you know identifying the
loops or the traps and the mistakes that
you're repeating there so that you can
kind of break
free break the chain ah and and continue
to evolve to continue to become more
enlightened more awakened more aware
more conscious yeah you know and like
you know it's like synchronicities I
call them you know people are like
there's no such thing as coincidence I
call synchronicities coin incidences
look at the spelling it's like Mario the
universe is giving you no synchronous
these are coins being basically put
before you yeah yeah yeah
and then you know you you already gave
us the answer you don't think we're in a
simulation that's our second I believe
it's real I mean it's more than that I
mean you could call it that but I think
that it is it sure it's much more real
than that it's a great game as you said
a great game but the universe is much
more complicated than you know we're all
I mean I know very little well yeah well
Universal kindergarten forever I love it
and then the last question we like to
ask on the show as we zoom into almost
Puerto Rico over there like kuba by the
way the greatest thing again call to
action greatest thing you can do for
Puerto Rico I mean at the simplest level
like he's come check it out yeah yeah
just take a trip there you have you
replace benefits by you visiting yes yes
of course of course and say you know hey
I mean show up with good intentions and
see you know if it cost you it is
paradise it's you know it's a giant
rainforest there you've got you know
bioluminescent Bay's more than anywhere
in the world I mean you're it's it's
it's enchanting yes yes it sounds
gorgeous absolutely need to visit then
that leads us to the question the last
one is what is the most beautiful thing
in the world you I mean I am you you or
me it's us it's like you know the most
important thing is you loving yourself
right it's back to you know selfishness
then then out into selflessness you know
learning to truly love yourself you know
you are you are the most beautiful thing
in the universe and once you start to
love thyself once you start to feel that
everything else starts to get
much more beautiful yeah and so I think
that's kind of the most important thing
problem we're all one and I guess I'll
close that one little ass because I'd
like words money take the word money the
first letter is money I mean M last
letters why or my if you take the me the
eye or the my out of money one your left
its one in the very middle yeah which is
all that matters we are all one take
them my off money and you get the one
Wow interesting
yeah giving this a lot of thought yeah
that's right that's right this has been
such a pleasure thank you so much for
coming on to the show it's been an honor
there's so much beautiful wisdom that
you've been unpacking and teaching us
about it yeah yeah we're really excited
from work for more rounds in the future
there's still a lot to teach and to
learn from you I'm huge thank you for
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let's get the community chatting
share share share more of the
conversations that we were talking about
today about digital currency and about
blockchain technology the impact that
has on the world go and share talk about
a more with your communities huge shout
out to Ron Vargas for producing and
directing thank you very much we greatly
appreciate you thank you and support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in go do cool things I go to
Puerto Rico visit the artists and
entrepreneurs they're the highest capita
of art evolved artists in the United
States I didn't know that the very
interesting statistic supports
simulation our links are below as well
helped us grow help us financially
stabilize we'd greatly appreciate that
and go and build the future everyone
manifest those dreams into the world we
love you so much and we will see you
soon peace
[Music]
[Music]